all right man so EP officially
so yeah Boys Don't Cry it's coming out
of the seventh of October October
October 7th we get the EP album by the
end of the year your first album first
ever it's crazy to think that this is
like technically your first album I mean
it's not that crazy because I'm like I'm
more so the artist that's under the
radar bro like you are for sure yeah
like so like a lot of I'm just I'll let
everybody do what they do because like
my thing is bro I wanted I wanted to
take all the proper steps and being that
I wanted to take all I've got the fan
base now yeah being that I wanted to
take all the proper steps on
it's like yo like like this [ __ ] got to
be done the right way
big features for the album yeah big
features I ain't even want to do no
features but but you did them because
they made sense yeah female featured
mail feature both both
I wouldn't mind hearing you LMA he said
you said you want my hearing me with
Janae no LMA or Janae Janae maybe too oh
either one hmm are you trying to say
janae's on the album I didn't say that I
feel like it did
you got a pregnant genev verse or prior
to the pregnancy verse which one was it
that is good bro [ __ ]
that's going to be amazing you said it
man yeah you said it wow you said it I
want to know what that sounds like
I want to know what it sounds like too
you know what it sounds like cause you
got it in your phone
you said I got a drake feature too I
mean I feel like you're the kind of
artist that Drake would just you would
just wake up on like a Saturday yeah a
drink would just hop on your [ __ ] yeah
I mean a lot of people's confused like I
remember when you first came out the
Tuesday slide was going on but you know
yeah a lot of people that was me
everybody thought it was you yeah no
hell no but you know I want a lot of old
bro the lover the you know the lover
boys don't usually connect the lover
boys like think about it like the lover
boys he's a lover boy and lover boy but
I'm nowhere close to Drake like if Drake
who else is a lover boy you Drake you
got like the the Brent fires is fire
yeah he toxic though he's his album is
[ __ ] up that's what they say about him
they say he toxic I ain't really talk so
I'm a good guy
would we consider Tori a lover boy he's
definitely a fighter boy
Dory uh definitely a lovely boy oh you
got a few bro
hey Tori's new album is hard I play I
heard that she said a rod to be a lover
boy Rod wave Rod's crazy yeah yeah you
and Rod ever uh connect
so he'll be on the new album too so
Broadway will be on it
you know what's great upgraded body
language so when I when I asked that
question and you said nothing how do you
know it's that though it's Broadway
rockaway's on the album so janaiko you
heard it here first we like have
exclusive the album's coming out top of
the year yeah we're gonna piss my fans
off they're gonna [ __ ] attractless
gonna come out just like this Rod wave
Janae
and and we're putting it into the air
we're gonna attract the Drake feature
we'll see if it happens yeah
you think you're better at basketball
than Drake
Drake I don't want no problems I just
want a song bro make the [ __ ] record
happen I just want a song bro
Drake
he's got the owl chain already
come on what are we doing Drizzy Drizzy
owes me fifty thousand dollars by the
way no way I swear to God
we made a bet
why would he say this on my episode I
already said it on a Drake
Drake you owe me 50K you remember you
remember bro Sun's made it to the final
show me a few thousand dollars